it's gamescom 2014 I'm Sean McGinnis
this is Danielle Dwyer and mr. O'Dwyer
here has just checked out a little bit
of battlefield hardline oh yeah new
battlefield game from the makers of
Dante's Inferno and also a dead space
and dead space well but what do you
think yeah Visceral Games they showed
off the single player today is first
time I'd seen it the first time they
shown a specific level and two things
came to mind okay first of all they are
really trying to make this not a linear
game really considering what battlefield
4 and 3 worry and four yeah kind of okay
maybe all right unfortunately they said
this isn't a single linear game and then
they've had a ten-minute section where
he just elbowed people in the back of
the head until he got his guns back but
he had the choice to elbowed him in the
head no he didn't know how to do it oh
he had it okay I once you got out of
this sort of the captive environment
I'll talk too much bass if exudes
literally from the center of the game
and you basically ended up at the
outside of a base like you I didn't say
far cry 3 and it's full of loaded tunes
you've got an objective in the middle
and they're like you could take this a
bunch of different ways you could pop
over the fence on the right you could
climb under the fence on the
or you can go in all guns blazing guess
what they did all guns blazing
that's the one it is went in start
shooting dudes and then at a certain
stage you win Oh actually I'll reload
the checkpoint why I'm just kidding and
you can went in a stealthy okay and this
presents the sort of the biggest I feel
like it's one of the best things about
our field hard line is that you can use
stealth and arrest people or you can
kill people and it also provides its
biggest kind of problem which is that
this is basically a police brutality
simulator ah did you did you do the
thing or see the thing we're like he
knocks the guy down and like it's got
his foot on spanking like handcuffs him
and that's have a thing this guy so when
he went in Southie yeah he put the gun
up and there's this kind of mini game we
have to make sure you you keep the gun
on the guys are they gonna go for the
pistols yeah and then when he hit the
arrest bought and he straight up like
just like like buying on cuff him and
just threw this dude on the ground like
yeah [ __ ] and then there was
this one optional objective which was
actually good which was when he before
he went in with the stealth he used
their binoculars too far Christ I'll
pick at everyone okay and he came up on
one of the guys oh so by taking him at
his name character who actually are in
money which then translates TV my fellow
guns
in the market the Quahog here's a
question you're you're a policeman sure
ethically the you know the local
government that you work for would
provide weapons for you to do your job
why are you buying guns Danny I think
maybe Nick Mendoza is that is operating
um not in not in broad daylight it's not
entirely above water yeah he's okay I
feel like he's mostly killing all these
Hillbillies who are really poorly
trained to fighting him back without
consent from the government okay yes
it's like I swear to god these guys were
standing in the middle of rub dirt track
right like there was a sofa there to
stand behind and this hillbilly was just
like loading shots into the side of a
his hillbilly trailer and he just kept
and so like a I was exactly the smartest
thing ever I don't know I feel like they
are trying to make this you know a
something bigger than a straight-up
linear single-player campaign I'm not
really sure if they have had the time to
do so and they've definitely done it
definitely looks more like mechanically
engaging than than three and four were
and it still has like it's very polished
it looks great it sounds great and you
know the facial animation stuff is
pretty impressive at times it looks very
much like all about
exultate three and four what I saw I was
more I'm more impressed by what from
what I saw them what I thought when I
went in but the jury's still out on
whether you know have dynamic this game
is shortly alright well hopefully we
find that out soon that's a guy's
battlefield hardline here at Gamescom
2014 it just got me